j'accueille également sur ce plateau
yann wehrling bonsoir porte-parole du
modem vous êtes conseiller de paris
merci d'être avec mes ring les
négociations sont elles définitivement
rompu entre la grèce et ses créanciers
ce soir mais je crois qu'il faut pas
envisager le pire
c'est vrai que monsieur tsipras ça a
joué avec le feu il a fait sans
référendum et les grecs n'ont pas
répondu à la question de savoir si vous
voulez sortir de la zone euro pas ils
ont répondu à une autre question
absolument la question donc ils ont
répondu ah je pense qu'au fond ils ont
envie de rester dans la zone euro les
grecs et je crois qu'il faut pas
souhaité que la grèce sorte de la zone
euro se serait ni bon pour les grecs ni
bon pour les européens et maintenant les
négociations doivent reprendre mais en
même temps c'est aussi à monsieur type
race de maintenant faire des
propositions des choses ont été faites
de part et d'autre peut-être que
beaucoup de choses ont été cafouilleuse
ces derniers temps et que maintenant
alors se remettre à l'ouvragé mais
monsieur type race doit faire des
propositions très claires sur comment il
voit la restructuration comment ils
voient les réformes de fond qui sont
attendus de lui est ce qu'il y aura un
cadastre demain en grèce par exemple est
ce qu'on pouvoir lever des impôts
correctement comme dans tous les pays
voilà des questions claires qui lui sont
prévus il ya des conséquences aussi en
matière de politique intérieure
suite à ce référendum grec yann wehrling
est ce que les politiques d'austérité
qui sont en échec un bien le
gouvernement français de voir en tenir
compte à l'avenir
en tout cas on peut pas dire comme j'ai
entendu françois hollande que la crise
grecque n'aura aucune conséquence sur
notre pays
c'est juste pas vrai je pense que si
demain
la grèce sortait de la zone euro il y
aurait des conséquences pour la france
il y aurait des conséquences sur les
taux d'intérêt et il ne faut pas croire
que parce que la grèce sortirait de la
zone euro les problèmes pour la grèce
elle même serait réglé et encore mois
pour l'europe
jeanne entendra l'instant la porte
parole du parti socialiste qui disait
que ce serait même un impact sur
l'ensemble de la zone euro parce que si
vous n'êtes pas capables de maintenir
l'unité dans la zone euro si vous
montrer cette image là à l'échelle
internationale et notamment après de
ceux qui prêtent aujourd'hui un certain
d'état de l'europe pour ben justement
aussi assumer un certain nombre de leurs
dépenses publiques et bien les taux
d'intérêt vont monter pour tous ses
états de la zone euro
et ça va être un effet enchaîne donc il
faut absolument évidemment faire en
sorte que tout cela à bas les
enseignements c&cu avant tout qu'il va
falloir maintenant qu'on comprenne que
les dettes sont des choses qu'il faut
rembourser quoi qu'il arrive qu'on
serait ce tout qu'on sorte de la zone
euro la grèce aura remboursé ses dettes
tout comme la france tout comme tous les
pays de la zone euro et il ya on va dire
quelque chose de logique à tout ça
arrive à norbourg sais c'est mal mais
elle le connaît l'allemagne rembourser
d'être comme tous les pays mais vous
affirmer ça mais en fait d'une
conférence nombre suivant 53 la culture
et économie de manière un peu hasardeuse
demande d'arrêt des choses qui
ressemblent à barrable mais aujourd'hui
on a une zone rouge en haut lieu
de fonctionnement qui s'appuie sur de la
solidarité et en même temps sur des
efforts et les efforts aujourd'hui ne
sont pas faits du côté de l'adresse et
la solidarité s'est appliqué donc ma
main si on veut continuer les primaires
aujourd'hui mais on demande des efforts
autant d'autres neuf pays non je suis
désolé concerne deux roues souffre
arrêtez arrêtez la franchise qui ne lève
qui nous avait sonné inédit la ressource
mais ils sont pas choses évoluent on
était une équipe